all
right all right guys well you know given
the awesome talks of this conference it
seems that Network States and startup
cities are are starting to get more
momentum and they're starting to get
more real world momentum so we need to
start talking about security uh from
Prosper prais you know as as these uh
projects go from the cloud to the land
security becomes a pretty big
concern so uh I'm currently the the
co-founder of of bit we we're incubating
Cantina which is a a Marketplace for
smart contract code review and and
penetration testing uh previously I was
a officer in the United States Army for
four years so I was an artillery officer
uh and then I was pulled up to the
Pentagon to be a product manager for a
large cyber security organization uh and
I'm also adviser to think tank in DC uh
foundation for American innovation which
is a think tank that actually has a a
charter City and startup City
purview okay so let me set the stage uh
I think in in the space uh you know on
crypto Twitter there's been this idea
floating in the air that uh you know
Network states are going to be fully
Sovereign right uh governments are not
going to be able to touch them uh and
the these Network States will be
ideologically pure and removed from the
international legal
system uh so I went out and I
interviewed a bunch of startup City
Founders and even going back uh to the
history of the startup City Movement
Like Patrick Freeman's blog back in the
in the late 2000s even then and it's
been proven out now uh there's been this
concept that maybe Network States and
maybe startup cities aren't going to be
fully Sovereign right that they're going
to really work in conjunction with host
Nation governments uh and that's what's
what's playing out right so um you know
sovereignty actually can be a burden uh
you know having to sustain a military
actually can be eeve negative
uh it's not always something you want so
maybe a more pragmatic lens is to you
know offload some aspects of sovereignty
to a a larger government and then really
focus on on the user experience of your
network state or or startup City you
know creating a safe environment for
your citizens and and your
users okay so let's kind of go through
the progression of the of the security
model here so you know I think the
Assumption in the room is that these
Network states are going to start in the
cloud right you aggregate a community
based on shared values uh and then
you're probably going to want to
crowdfund something so the advice there
would be to use uh secure smart Dow
contracts that have been audited by a
reputable security firm uh and then
you're going to want to you know speak
and coordinate so in that case use you
know secure messaging like like signal
and some other tools because you know
free speech is important right I think
we all support Free Speech here um and
there are some projects in the ecosystem
shout out to uh infin VC that put this
together so logos is a is a blockchain
that is is marketing itself to to
network states with a private messaging
service uh urbit uh not necessarily
marketed directly for for Network States
but potentially some some use there with
you know decentralized messaging uh and
so on and there's also C and lexow which
allow you to spin up uh regulated uh
crowdfunding okay so I think everyone in
the room is you know relatively familiar
with cyber security um maybe the the
tech tribe isn't as familiar with the
security model
when we transition uh from the cloud to
land right because it's Cloud first but
not land never so it's a different
mentality here uh once we we go to to
land after we've we've crowdfunded a a
physical territory um the model shifts
from one of abundance to one of
protecting scarcity um and again there
there's no real need to have offensive
military capability here none of the the
startup City Founders I've talked to
really want that uh instead it's more of
a public safety lens
to protect sites and protect the
residents that are going to occy these
these new developments okay so the
question then becomes can
cryptography and can drones be the
primary means of Defense it's a sexy
idea right we can offload it all to to
Robotics and to to math uh at least in
2023 the answer is that is a necessary
but not sufficient way to defend any
piece of territory around the world so
that that photo it's a pretty Stark one
it's the the border wall between Gaza
and Israel and the Israelis had the
mentality uh that they were going to
become the startup nation and focus on
cryptography through cyber security uh
focus on drones focus on robotics you
know that there was a bunch of um you
know robotic video cameras that were
monitoring the wall uh and they didn't
have enough you know troops to guard the
wall uh and obviously the attack uh
recently happened because of that
so some objections uh to this thesis
that I have and frankly that's been
proven out by a lot of the the Ser City
Founders I've talked to one common one
is hey you know these these Network
states are going to be secured by
Bitcoin Bitcoin is cloud first um it may
be Cloud first but there's still real
world attack vectors uh with the mins
are physical but even more pragmatically
uh if you look at crowdfunding today
it's it's with less uh
decentralized uh you know forms of of
crypto than than Bitcoin it's more
likely that Network states are going to
use USD or usdt for for daily operations
that pay people to buy real estate and
so on um and then you know for the the
second objection which is uh you know
information age defense is dis
proportionable about cryptography you
know the the crypto field itself is
always known about $5 wrench crypto
analysis right the the rubber hose
attack so that that's been a no un
Threat
Vector um and then some other objections
to this thesis that you know we're in
the Agee of AI and so on I think Elon
would probably disagree that's why
neuralink exists right to help humans a
m in the age of AI but even before that
you know militaries today are working on
human machine teaming which is you know
having human pilots in conjunction with
drones because AI is good at certain
things humans are good at others so
again I think that that falls flat and
then finally uh the expression you can't
nuk network uh but you can certainly
assassinate the the people that comprise
it okay so not to be a Doomer I think
there's some positives here and there's
a lot of stuff for maybe Founders in
this room to build uh that can help
solve some of these problems
um so the the founders I talk to that
are building these these startup cities
were pretty unanimous they're looking at
kind of like a campus police model right
where similar to you know in in America
you have universities that have local
police departments that prosecute Major
Crimes uh but then you do have campus
police which really are focused on like
you know smaller order crimes on the
college campus so that's the model that
the these founders of startup cities are
going for um and then you couple that
with uh Public Safety tax so a great
example is flock a flock technology
which is an American uh startup that
builds gunshot detectors and they build
license plate readers and just getting
started uh there's a lot of
opportunities for Founders to build a
better Public Safety Tech to to help out
here um Network States and startup
cities are also going to need
misinformation defense um whether we
like it or not you know the internet is
a it's a it's a battlefield I think
again these last two to three weeks have
have proven that out that the The
Narrative uh Warfare is is real um and
it just is what it is um so the overall
takeaway here uh you know first is with
cyber security uh so there's some books
you can read about the history of you
know zero days and all that good stuff
Nicole perov wrote a good book on that
you can hire Cantina which is the the
marketplace that's Spirit been incubated
we got you covered for for code review
and for penetration testing um and then
again like as the text Drive starts to
tease out what in-person developments
look like I think it's important to
understand the culture of of of those
folks that have had a you know a more
scarce life so maybe folks in the
Special Operations Community Sean Ryan
is a great example that he's a for an a
SE that interviews a bunch of Special
Operations veterans and I think it's
it's good for for Tech folks to
understand that culture uh and then of
course um the opportunity to hire campus
police for these startup City
developments in coordination with local
governments working underneath the
international legal system I think it's
a win-win for everyone uh and then
finally uh with information War John
robs and blogging about kind of the the
tactics of information War for a while
um and you know these these new
developments are going to have to hire
uh social media
teams okay but the the main takeaway is
and this is something that came up
multiple times as I was talking to to
Founders in the
space we need more
Statesmen
so the skill set
to run a B2B SAS
company although it's great and I'm not
trying to downplay that it's a great
accomplishment but that's a factory
floor
model there's no precedent for this at
least in recent history by this I mean
starting a new city or potentially even
a new
country so the mentality of Founders is
going to be
different and it's going to take folks
with some uh some Gusto maybe even some
konus so so that's the uh the main
takeaway
um but there's a lot of opportunity to
build so let's get after it
thanks